check this out twitter bands far right
extremist group the oath keepers
the company says the group violated its
policies on violent extremist group
the first question i have is ian do you
know who those keepers are i'm just
learning about them today
do you i do do you think they're an
extremist group they are not
i don't think they're like the three
percenters yeah i think they're just
like
well i think they've been pushing the
rhetoric for sure yeah
okay well what they're like middle-aged
guys who really want to do something and
this is what they do on saturday
afternoons is the bye bye kind of get
off them
they show the protests and they walk
around and i'm not convinced they're
going to do anything crazy
isn't isn't like the the general concept
of the group is that they're staunch
constitutionalists
yeah i think that's why they're called
oath keepers this is going to be really
interesting
you know because we we got problems man
i'll tell you what um
i'm not a fan of people calling for
violence i think we gotta simmer
everything down
but i've been i've been having
conversation after conversation about
how the constitution is swiss cheese
are are that it doesn't even matter for
the most part guideline at the very
least
i mean not even anymore there's there's
there's like no penalty for any of these
lawmakers proposing
unconstitutional laws and getting them
passed and then violating people's
rights
it's just a well it's on it's incumbent
upon you to sue if your rights were
violated
what what's an example of something is
there anything i mean on the top of your
head
if you want to look to be fair there are
a lot of things in
the constitution that like rules have
been imposed based on supreme court
rulings
specifically on the second amendment's
the easiest one but
search and seizure would be violated
every day okay
like metadata spying oh that's really
nsa
the nsa spying stuff that snowden
revealed like that's really obvious the
cia got invented in like the 40s
and that didn't exist when they wrote
the concept i'm gonna give a mention to
uh caitlin bennett
you know who she is she's the gun rights
activist from kent state is it she's
alma mater what up yeah okay so so this
video going around today of her
and she is this angry mob screaming you
know fu and stuff and the cop says
you have to leave and she's like why i
didn't do anything in the cop says i
can't control these people
so we're going to leave we'll make you
leave because it'll you know be safe and
then she says
a very good point if you can't control
them now you're not going to be able to
control them even if i leave
and that's true but this is a really
good example the police straight up
saying we will
violate your rights in order to make our
job easier
that's it so so the the police they do
this all the time
they will like us they will arrest you
saying you're you're out of line you're
interfering with police work because the
crowd's angry at you and this is because
they're fearing for their own personal
safety it's it's the it's the way i've
often described it
if if you put a human being in front of
a giant angry screaming mob
and they say okay i can i can try and
get a ton of officers to stop this mob
or i can just arrest the one person oh
that's a slippery slope but that's what
they do
that's what i see so so listen this is
why i've explained that as
as the chaos and the calamities
escalates there's a real fear
that with these these extremists showing
up to the homes of of mayors and police
chiefs like
they showed up to the home of carmen
best the seattle police chief and uh
the neighbors came out with guns
eventually they're gonna come to
someone's house and the mob is gonna be
so large
the people there like imagine if a mob
showed up in front of our house
and then we're like what do we do call
the police the police show up and see
300 people screaming and throwing bricks
and
rabble rabble rabble and they're like oh
man what do we do and they're like
what do what do these people want and
they're like arrest them their nazis
arrest them
the cops are like we can't stop them and
they're going to hurt a lot of people
but if we arrest the people in this
house maybe they'll stop
so the police capitulating the mob
justice is
unconstitutional of course the police
can't
can't do anything about it because
they're not strong enough a cop
arresting
you for free for expressing your free
speech rights because other people are
threatening you
right like you're not committing any
crimes wait the cop didn't threaten to
arrest caitlyn
he kicked her i mean did he actually
effectively kick her out and did he even
have backup or was he like a security he
remembered her
and and i'd be willing to bet she would
have been arrested if she said no
remember when ben shapiro tried speaking
at that event
and they and the cop was like if you
cross this line you will be arrested i
remember that
yeah exactly what did ben shapiro do no
nothing he was
he was going to speak at a college
campus protesters showed up started
screaming rabble rabble rebel
and then uh ben was like i'm supposed to
speak here and the cops like i don't
care is it because the cops job is to
keep the peace at a local level
whatever the national law or state law
is it's the local piece
i don't know first priority i don't know
man
i don't know if their priority is
supposed to be keeping the peace
but i'll tell you this i have a right to
speak i have a first amendment right
if other people are committing crimes
the police need to arrest those
committing crimes
not me and and peace can come from like
subduing who you hate like if a crowd
goes and wants to lynch somebody
if they get to lynch the guy then there
might be peace afterwards
but is that justice it won't be though
let's be real if
if if they're all if they get away with
this like they do with ben they will
keep doing it realizing it works a
tactic
yeah yeah yeah so anyway let's go back
to what's going on with the oath keepers
the reason i bring all that up is
they're staunch constitutionalists
they're banned now because they're
basically one of the things this guy
tweeted
and i don't agree with it he said the
shots have been fired
the the guy who died in portland and he
says we're gonna give trump one more
chance to declare this a marxist
insurrection otherwise
you know we're gonna take action or
something like that and so there's
there's very serious questions that are
asked among very politically charged
groups
even antifa at what point are they
allowed to
have a violent redress of grievances
against the government
that's a scary thought i think they
should avoid doing that if you study the
russian revolution at all this is
kind of interesting calling it marxist
because when capitalism starts to fail
as what it did in you know 20th early
20th century the great depression was
coming on
um there other people look for other
methods of economy and communism was the
main one and so it looks like
people are in a similar situation with
coven shutting everything down
people losing their and so they're
better than ever
um technically yeah society in general
the poorest among us have it better than
the richest 200 years ago i would argue
definitely
but responding to that
uprising that with violence like they
had the white army and the red army the
basically the the monarchs tried to stop
the communist uprising by creating a
white army
and fighting back against them so then
the communists created a red army and
fought back against them and just
escalated the violence
yeah so if i i don't want to re relive
that
who would you rather win the far left of
the far right i don't know who they are
that's the problem it's just extremists
are extremists
well hold on hold on the oath keepers
are
they they purport that they are staunch
constitutionalists
they don't seem far anything that's
middle of the road you think
i mean the constitution's legit yeah
that's right and then you have the far
left which are avowed marxists and
communists people that want a marxist
revolution is a little extreme to me it
didn't work the first it didn't work in
russia
um really really didn't work because you
have to put somebody in charge of like
everybody's property
yeah you can't do that if they had like
an ai system built out that was going to
be like a
literal like everyone had a piece and we
had you could measure it on like a
blockchain and see
and no human was involved with like
passing out anything it would just came
to us
i could see like a technological
revolution we wouldn't call i'd call it
something other than communism
who designs the ai it would have to be
free software it would have to be agreed
upon
voted on and then we'd have to see the
code well let me tell you something
if there was if there was i think one of
the ideas the far left has
in terms of their goal for revolution is
that if they can purge
any memory of liberty then people won't
crave what they don't know exists
you know what i mean like book burning
so yeah yeah right if
if right now actually have you seen
let's do some marvel references
have you seen uh uh captain america
winter soldier have you guys negative
oh yeah i've seen it that's the one
where uh the the bad guys took the hydra
infiltrated
that's what it is right hydra
infiltrated yeah and then they want to
have the giant helicarriers just
kill all the undesirables oh geez yeah
they're like if we kill
you know three billion people those are
the ones who cause the problems then
we'll have a bunch of you know
just like sheeple i guess they use that
word but the general idea is
they think that if no one if you have a
society
that from birth was raised to never
understand concepts of freedom
then they would be happy ignorance is
bliss and that seems to be a tactic that
they kind of go for that's why
everything they do is a lie everything
is manipulative everything is deception
for me that's in the antithesis of like
life what you're supposed to do explore
create
experience and so they want to create a
rigid
gray colorless you know cube world where
everything's like
just have you read a wrinkle in time oh
man
i was like you do not want that world
what is that world that's the gray
colorless
mother brain controlling everything
world the borg
yeah basically and then you have the
board queen controlling everything funky
it does feel like we're headed towards
borg
reality man would you are you going to
get the neural link i'm going to let
the people that have debilitating
injuries test it for
10 years you know five years kind of
like a right to try thing almost and if
they turn out to be superhuman and have
mega access to the internet yeah super
cool like the new orleans people yeah
so there's a an outer limits episode
about this where everyone is connected
to something called the stream
but then like the general idea of the
stream is to give people access to
knowledge so they have these brain
implants
and they don't think for themselves for
the most part they don't have to they'll
be like
there's a door and then they'll think
like it just streams the information
right
to their brain so they know where
everyone is they know what everyone is
doing
and so there's one guy who's got some
kind of like neurological issue where he
can't get an implant
he has to read books he's a normal guy
but they call him disabled because he
can't
access the stream right but then
something happens where
the stream's goal is to like acquire
information and provide that information
to people
but everything is information so it
starts creating information where it's
like how many hairs can you pull out of
your head
just like arbitrarily oh that sounds
like twitter because i'm just kidding no
no but but
but right that's kind of what i'm
getting to where
you and you'll end up with a bunch of
people like you look at look how bad
twitter is
right is it even a bad thing that
twitter has banned you know the oath
keepers in a sense because like i don't
know why they ban them
well because i they were posting things
like you know the first shot has been
fired and whatever well that other girl
was posting exactly
the violent stuff we're talking about
yesterday yesterday that's a good point
if it wasn't imminent calls for violence
then they i don't think they should have
been banned
exactly was that ladies and gentlemen
look her up
oh crap i don't remember um i agree with
what you say about
about removing information i think if
someone's in that path i don't agree
with them whether they're far
this or that yeah you know what i was
thinking too the fact that if you did
take liberty away from us within a
generation everyone
would have forgotten because people
adapt so quickly this is why we've come
up with like word of mouth like
storytelling this is why we write stuff
down and write books and we communicate
with our children it's because we don't
want to forget the stuff that happened
before us we stopped doing it
this has happened and before we know it
we're going to lose all this stuff we
work for
it's like have you have you guys seen uh
stargate yeah the movies like we're just
doing movie references
yeah tonight is movie reference when
james spader's the man when they meet
the people they can't write because the
the aliens realize that humans having
the ability
to share information and and record it
allowed them to fight like realize their
freedom and their rights
and so the the enslaved people on the
other planet are like scared of writing
but because of this they can't organize
properly slaves weren't allowed to learn
to read or write and they had a verbal
tradition too
this is why they banned people from the
internet interesting do you think that
liberty is a natural human desire
yeah okay then you can never stop it
this is
listen they just banned
uh the oath keepers like today i guess i
think so i think so yeah so i made this
point right
we talk a lot about civil unrest the
potential for civil war and all this
stuff
and i hear all the time from the right
they're like we if there's ever a war
we're going to crush
the left yeah and they like high five
and chess bomb stuff i'm kidding but
they say like the left won't
won't know what hit them because we have
all the guns and stuff and my response
is
your your internet will kind of will cut
off you're going to be sitting in your
house and you're going to be like i'm
ready if these people want to take my
constitution i'm ready to fight and then
all of a sudden your internet goes out
and you're like i wonder what's
happening then what do you do
they're all organized now because they
because they control social media
twitter twitter just banned the oath
keepers and they allowed this black
lives matter woman who said violence is
the only way to stay up
this huge screed about how they have to
get violent
and that's allowed to stay and it's been
up for days
and you have antifa actively organizing
on the platform and the oath keepers
gone i wish i saw what what literally
was the thing that banned them
is that is that public knowledge um let
me let me see if that's another problem
with banning someone is you lose access
to what it was that got them banned and
then how do you that's a good point
because they're like how extreme are
they actually because i know that people
like to call
anybody right of mao you know far right
or whatever here
check this out from talking points memo
with itchy trigger fingers some right
wingers predict the next civil war has
finally arrived and they say quote
the first the first shot has been fired
brother said stuart
rhodes founder of the armed
anti-government group oathkeepers i
don't think they're anti-government i
think they're constitutionalists
he says quote civil war is here right
now we'll give trump one last chance to
declare this a marxist insurrection and
suppress it
as his duty demands if he fails to do
his duty we will do
ours hmm yeah
i would contest too that being
constitutionalist is
being anti-government because the entire
point of the constitution was to
constrain not the people
the government what that guy typed is
legal but
twitter's uh terms isn't about what's
ever legal in the u.s that's the one
thing that's obvious
is it's like what's legal can do on the
platform so that would be allowed on
minds
but on twitter it's i don't know what
their terms are probably what and you
mentioned
we talked about the other day the ladies
saying violence is the only way or
whatever yeah and you said that would
also be
it's not imminent violence it's not
saying do this violent thing on this day
at this time
because then you're calling for imminent
violence that is illegal so that would
come off mines
excitement but just saying let's get
dirty let's go let's kill them i mean
it's crazy to say that but
it's legal really yeah wow is that crazy
not saying let's kill this person
what do you said like i'm so angry
everyone burn it all down burn it off
yeah it's too vague
it's legal that's vague yeah that's
saying burn it all because you're not
saying burn it all down at 2 pm on
tuesday
is it the courthouse yeah for sure what
do you mean it's imminent becomes an
imminent threat
if you say go do this right if you said
everyone go out burn it down because
because there was a guy who actually
said that right like during ferguson
yeah i think he was like burn it all
down just something like that
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time